ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show audio only episode how
[ __ ] are we how disrespectful
what contempt we have for our fans
we're back in the studio next week we're
having the studio
amped up we're moving we got a new space
in austin the studio is going to look
the same
don't worry your little heads about it
it's going to be great
but we need to have it done we're having
the pillows fluffed and the curtains
steamed and
the neon sign is being moved and
all of that and and i want to apologize
for
canceling some of the spots in la i am
no longer in la
i am not in la all of the instagram
photos that i have uploaded at sushi
restaurants and at the beach
are from other places they were taken
years ago and uploaded today
i am not here i want to perform in
backyards and alleys
i'm listen here's the deal with with
spots you people have to realize this
and i and and i'm i'm terribly
saddened by the fact that many people
don't get this when i do a spot
on a show i am doing a
10 minute set maybe 15 potentially 12.
it is not my show i am not headlining it
i have no control over the show i don't
know when
i'm gonna go up and if i book a lot of
those spots in a night
sometimes with la traffic and [ __ ] like
that i can't get to one of them truly
and sometimes when it's a place like the
haha comedy club which i don't
didn't know anything about but it was an
alley with 12 people in it i walk in and
then i walk out
because i don't want to be there you see
i want to do
something else so i do it and i'm
sorry that you bought seven tickets to
it for your
birthday your birthday
at the haha comedy club in an alley it's
not
tim dillon's headlining and we're gonna
have a great time it's tim dylan's going
and doing ten minutes
probably the majority of which is me
going on stage going i don't want to be
here
i walked into the haha comedy club which
is it was
outside they're not inside it's outside
and there were
eight audience members or ten that i
counted there was a girl on stage a
white girl with like a bob marley hat
going if aliens land they're just gonna
go on rogan and do dmt
i don't know who this person is i have
not booked her
i am sorry you had to suffer through
that i apologize for that
but this is what happens when i do i
don't do a ton of spots i'm usually out
on the road
doing my own shows headlining and those
are the shows that
i show up to and are good and i try to
do the other ones but sometimes
there's a problem there's traffic
there's crime
there's homeless and that
prevents me from getting to the spot
because i'm on my way the i was on the
way to a spot and i i tripped and fell
into a sushi restaurant for three hours
and it happens because of the violence
on the streets
i was i was walking down the street and
then there was a gang of palestinians
beating me up and i said i'm an irish
catholic
and the only refuge i uh could take was
to spend
three hours eating sushi and not
going to the thing i apologize
when it's a headlining show it's a
headlining show
you know when it's a spot and i'm doing
10 minutes i try to get to all of them
that i can
and it it it should be a thing where if
you like the whole lineup go
don't go just for me go if you like
everybody if you go i love
i like the scar brothers good go to that
go we're it's a it's a it's a a group
effort
is what i'm saying you could stay home
and watch barbin star the new movie
barbie start which i can't recommend
uh more i mean barb and star
it's so good it doesn't have a plot and
there's no jokes but it's very
brightly colored it's brightly colored
and it's very um serene
there's blues and greens and there's
musical numbers and it's some snl alum
uh getting their funny on uh so you can
you can always watch barbie star but
genuinely
message me if you bought a lot of
tickets to the haha
comedy uh uh parking lot
and you're offended that you could not
see me do 12 minutes
i apologize i will try to get you into
some of the headlining shows
but this is the difference between when
a comedy show is a headlining show that
i am putting on and a show that i'm
being promoted on the lineup but i
really don't know what's going on and i
tried to get to the haha
the the first time not the second um
but the problem is if you book too many
of these spots in a night it's hard to
get to all that and
and i and i try but a lot of these shows
in l.a god bless everyone they're in
backyards
some of them are very fun and support
them but support them because you love
comedy not just me
there's a lot of me out there and and
and uh
there's other people out there you know
i just
it's it's you know doing spots is
something i've done for 12 years
it's it's not as fun anymore uh doing
them it's not as fun anymore
to have to make small talk with anthony
jeselnik who
shared an article saying that comedy had
an alt-right problem that the new
republic decided to publish
uh anthony jeselnik who made his bones
doing boston marathon bombing jokes
has now decided he's the arbiter of what
is and isn't appropriate to be said on
stage
and i have to go and speak to him like
he's an actual human being
that's what i have to do that's part of
my career i have to uh
speak to him like he's a person he's a
great joke writer
the comedy's not really for me i'm more
interested in human beings carbon based
life forms
but what he does is you know great and
people love it
but that's what spots are i have to sit
in a green room and uh
talk to him uh even though i know that
he shared an article
uh that seeks to uh take everybody that
i know his career away
um but you know we i gotta sit there and
go yeah
how are you oh they're good yeah the
audience is good good to see you
and i [ __ ] on austin all the [ __ ]
time i [ __ ] on it all the time but
you know a lot of these people in la i
mean they've got another thing coming
i don't know what the hell they think is
going to go on i mean you guys can you
do spots for the rest of your life
do spots and stand in parking lots and
smoke cigarettes for the rest of your
life i don't
you know hey enjoy that good
enjoy that and let me know when you can
afford that uh 12 million dollar house
out here let me know
let me know when you can afford that 12
million
home let me know when your vision board
starts to work out
keep me updated keep me abreast of that
because i got a nice house and it ain't
big
it's fine and it's big enough for me
and we're gonna pay that we're gonna
we're gonna podcast and make content
we're gonna do shows on the road
and we will come to la uh from time to
time to do spots
and just understand what those spots are
i mean it's
you know it's not something where i can
really uh control everything that
happens i do my best
uh to get to the spots i do i do my best
but there are
there are there are problems with
getting to all
those spots there are dinners there are
things i'd rather do there is
laying in a bed there is smoking
cigarettes on the street
there is talking to a hotel valet and
deciding that i find him more
interesting than doing it
there are all kinds of problems because
of the violence because of the
homelessness
do you see lori lightfoot mayor of
chicago who
i can't describe how much i enjoy
lori lightfoot i can barely put into
words
how obsessed i am with this woman
uh she's uh somebody messaged me on
instagram and they said you try
reasoning with this
menace she's a menace she's destroying
one of the great american cities but
somebody else would be if she wasn't and
she's a lot of a fun she looks like a
batman villain she's a lesbian
and there's all kinds of rumors that
she's like cheating on her wife
and uh you know she's uh i don't know
using state money and she's taking like
broads to shitty hotel rooms and i mean
she's now refusing to talk to anybody
who's not black she won't talk to white
reporters anymore
uh there's pictures of her with these
big balloon pants like she wears
ill-fitting clothes they don't fit and
i mean she's just an absolute legend she
wears uh
you know these weird like uh suits
and then she wears uh these fedoras and
she walks around like a batman villain
like i picture her like
walking down the street in a zoot suit
with a fedora on and a cane just
you know hitting homeless people but
lori lightfoot azar is is our hero here
she's our hero
and she's forcing the if you want to
talk to her in chicago you're going to
have to do blackface
if you are a reporter in chicago that is
white
and you want to talk to lori lightfoot
you have to do blackface she's given you
no choice you should be
you should not be
uh even in the slightest bit of trouble
for painting your face black to talk to
the mayor of chicago lori lightfoot if
you are
curious as to what's going on but laurie
uh has an open invitation on this show i
will get a black
translator here and i will ask questions
to the black person to then be asked to
laurie lightfoot
because we like laurie so much we
appreciate
she's a goon and if there if there's one
thing that we respect and we love and we
appreciate
it is a goon and uh
we love her and we just want to say that
even though we're white and by the way
we're sorry about that we had very
little control over it
we wouldn't trade it as louis c.k said
because it does seem to be easier
but not now because we want to talk to
lori lightfoot in fact that's
every day i just want to speak uh to
lori lightfoot and
and see i mean her name just her name
is perfect everything about her is
absolutely perfect
my dream is a caitlyn jenner lori
lightfoot
presidential ticket caitlyn of course
headlining it more name recognition
but lori lightfoot as the vp kind of
like a dick
cheney a power player behind the scenes
pokes are fedora wearing head out every
now and then
shuffles on the stage in an ill-fitting
suit and then lays down the law
that's what we hope that's what we're
going for
um but we are
kind of unironically supporting caitlyn
jenner on this show
um i like caitlyn i think she's
an example of true diversity in a
country that claims to want it
and does not we do not want diversity
we want young good-looking
ethnically diverse but usually
ethnically ambiguous
people that all have the same life
experiences
views thoughts we like mediocrity
uh we do not like um greatness
and caitlyn say what you will
is an example of greatness decathlete
olympian how many gold medals do we know
oh let me see
i mean a woman who has
truly lived
many lives and she's
she's what the state of california needs
yeah and 76 for the decathlon won the
gold medal
yes amazing she's a denizen of the
country club
she's a denizen of the she likes
diversity the way
a lot of people of her generation like
it they like seeing it on tv
they don't want it too close
they um you know she doesn't really
love the homeless
she wants them gone she's a country club
uh trans person who
murdered two people in a car
and acts like it doesn't happen she's
just heading down the pch
a hundred miles an hour remembering the
good times remembering people
putting gold medals around her neck
before she was subjugated to a
tertiary role in that family of
armenians that lived in calabasas
caitlyn strutted around that house like
a nobody like a nothing
like an afterthought while everyone else
engaged in
feuds and scandals caitlyn
just kind of played it close to the vest
very quietly would go out and golf
offer a few words of wisdom when asked
but rarely asked
caitlin was really an afterthought on
that show but all the while
caitlyn was sitting there going i am
cooking up
a way to come back big
big and caitlyn
had known for a while that that caitlyn
who was known at that time as
we will say like voldemort the is the
name that cannot be mentioned because it
will be dead naming and we will be
kicked off
but caitlyn there was another iteration
of caitlyn
bouncing around and caitlyn knew
that that wouldn't do she said i've
always felt like caitlyn
and but i don't want to change who i am
i don't want to ch
i don't want to not be rich and i don't
want to not
be uh you know
a person that likes law and order
and money and country clubs
she likes that and why shouldn't she
she's good at things right caitlyn does
things
very well so she likes people who
also do things very well yeah she's a
bit insensitive
yes the only mexican people she's spoken
to are giving her guacamole
i understand that i understand that
maybe
she's a little culturally unhip if you
will
caitlyn spent a little too long on the
golf course
a little too much time in calabasas
doesn't really
uh regard uh diversity as anything else
uh other than like uh a quinceanera on a
malibu beach that's getting a little
too loud
but caitlyn's important this is an
important figure in america we need
more trans people that come from this
background
we don't need more trans nerds do we
do we need more tumblr trans people
i don't think so it's like we don't need
more gays
that are wearing leather and pink thongs
doing cartwheels down the street
we need more gays like me people who
look
like they work on the docks people who
look like they're a crooked cop or they
have a gambling addiction
people like me we need more of us we we
get it we get that gays some of them are
very fashionable
and uh you know white women like to keep
them in their purse and take them out
so that they can interpret them while
they get hammered in orange county
we understand that those and we know
that gays are
very talented and many of them are in
theater and
there are quite a few of them as flight
attendants telling you to put your mask
over your nose you know
clearly not a dream job but you can junk
up you can do a lot of drugs and then
[ __ ] people
in the different places you land and
then get out of there it's not the worst
job
for a gay but we just don't need more of
them in the public eye because we get it
in the same way we don't need more
tumblr trans people
we don't need more people who've lived
their entire lives
uh in a computer we don't need more
trans people that really like
anime what we need is a country club
trans [ __ ] that's not taking any [ __ ]
we need somebody to pull up in a bentley
and get out in a christian louboutin
la bhutan and walk into a restaurant and
sit down and if she spies the tent
on her way in she's unhappy
that's what we mean am i wrong
i am not wrong yes or yes
if trans people are to represent the
fullness of human experience as they
should
why in god's name wouldn't we have a
wealthy
trans olympian who's a bit out of touch
a little lucille bluth in her
she doesn't really tolerate uh too much
self-pity she doesn't like it you can
tell
that caitlyn jenner's a tough [ __ ] she
is
she doesn't really tolerate you if
you're going to she doesn't like the
whimpering
oh i don't have money oh i was just in
the middle lane on the pch
any of those things she doesn't like it
it doesn't matter because she's got
somewhere she wants to go
and it's usually a 12 000 square foot
beautiful desert home
and i am supporting her because i
unlike everyone else care about
diversity
and it would greatly help trans people i
had a joke when i first started comedy
we need more gay people and gangs
we need more violent gay people gay
people that other people are afraid of
you know in the same way that uh trans
people
we need strong trans people
uh insensitive trans people
people who have money and aren't ashamed
of it
people who are willing to tell you that
they are better than you
she's a conservative gal she
did an interview with sean hannity in
her airplane
hangar it was one of the greatest things
i've ever seen
a great spectacle of political theater
okay now miss lightfoot who we love
is not at this level yet hopefully she
will get there
but uh caitlyn is a spectacle not for
her
transition but for all the reasons that
i had mentioned
it's it's a total package she is dare i
say
the total package and what i love about
caitlyn is she speaks kind of like trump
off the cuff
she has called herself a disrupter she's
a disrupter
she's going to disrupt not only the
state of california which i imagine
she'll destroy in four to six months
but i don't care it's neither here nor
there to me i want to be entertained for
my
small house in texas it's not that big
but i want to be entertained i will of
course
be watching it very closely uh i imagine
caitlyn won't do anything
uh too much worse than gavin news some
although she might i don't know
um but i think california should have a
caitlyn jenner they had an
arnold schwarzenegger they should have a
caitlyn jenner and
as you listen to me you're kind of
agreeing with me here she's not gonna go
too
far to the right because she's trans and
and and and she gets it but she's not
gonna go too far to the left
because she's a multi-millionaire
olympian who's killed people
that's the different i know that she
killed them
on accident but here's what i like about
caitlyn and this is what i think a chief
executive needs
and the governor of the state is an
executive look at caitlyn jenner
listen to her talk do you think
she spends one minute
of her day thinking about the people she
killed
do you think when she's ordering i don't
know
huevos rancheros out there at the club
do you think she's sidelined even for a
minute
thinking about the two lives she ended
in malibu no
much like george h.w bush who probably
didn't think too much about his partner
when that plane went down years ago
go to the archives i think
caitlyn has shown tremendous strength in
being able to kind of just go on about
her day-to-day life
without thinking too much and who are
the people by the way that she killed do
we know
let me look it up because i know that
see if it's public i know it was an
accident when i say murderer i'm kidding
i don't think she did it intentionally
i'm just saying i don't think it keeps
her up at night which i think is
important
she's going to be making big decisions
and running a state
she can't always be guilt-ridden
stricken with feelings of despair oh
god it's the [ __ ] hello
how are you good
uh we can't unfortunately well what what
what time
what time does it become available
okay uh uh
what's the temperature like down there
what time is it now ben it's uh 1 51 p.m
uh
no sorry buddy we appreciate it thank
you
one of the cabanas became open we're on
a wait list
tea
but i can we can't do it now we're in
the middle of the show
i can't just leave here and go to a
cabana
but it's the high 60s grazing the 70s we
can go in the
pool though yeah see this is what i
think caitlyn jenner thinks about
instead of the two people that she left
dead on the side of the road
do you understand and why shouldn't she
yes there are problems
but caitlyn understands that problems
aren't real if you can't see them
here's something new you know how the
price of gold has been all over the
place lately now there's a way to buy
gold through a company called acre acre
lets you subscribe to gold bars for as
little as 30
a month you pay each month and once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they discreetly ship acre gold to your
house and just recently aker has
introduced
a new 100 a month subscription for a 5g
gold bar
acre lets you invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
acre keeps you updated on your gold
stash every month and ships
you once you reach the price threshold
with acre taking physical delivery of
your gold means it's safe and sound in
your hands
acre strips you go directly and
discreetly to your door acre
designs their gold in california and
sources their gold from one of the
largest mints in switzerland
it's actually very interesting because
acre gold is one of the few affordable
tangible things you can buy
that will be worth anything in five
years that's the part that blew my mind
all smart investors allocate some of
their money
to precious metals specifically gold
this is a fact
but the big takeaway here is that you
don't have to come out of pocket all at
once to acquire
meaningful gold over time it's a great
way to build a portfolio
little by little visit getacregold.com
acres a c r e get acre gold dot com
slash
tim dillon that's get acre gold dot com
slash tim dillon
and start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient mention at
get underscore acre again that's
getacoregold.com
tim dillon thank you acre gold for
supporting our show
if you started your own online store
you're doing what you love selling
products people
want and orders are coming in fast now
the hard part shipping those products
luckily shipstation makes it easy with
ship station it's impossible to import
manage and ship your orders out fast for
a lot less money
it's no wonder shipstation is the number
one shipping software for e-commerce
sellers
with more five-star reviews than anyone
else import orders from any sales
channel ship with any carrier using our
deeply discounted rates
automate just about any of any shipping
task spend lots of time on shipping and
a lot more on growing your business
no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own website chip station
funnels all your orders into one simple
interface
you can manage from anywhere even your
cell phone you'll even get access to
amazing discounts with major carriers
including ups fedex and usps
easily compare carriers and choose the
best solution every time
with ship stations small businesses can
now access the same rates usually
reserved for fortune 500 companies
without the contracts or commitments
ship more in less time just use my offer
code tim dillon
two months free 60-day trial 60 days is
two months
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page type in tim
dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
that's shipstation.com enter the offer
code tim dillon it's a great way to
support the show
this is a way to start a business with
two months free you can ship
all the stuff you're looking to do this
is the best way to do it online
i'm telling you who did she kill ben
okay so the local sheriff's department
determined she was driving her escalade
at an unsafe speed
when she rear-ended 69 year old widow
kim ho's lexus pushing her into oncoming
traffic
hoe died after crashing head-on into the
wolf
molasses so so only only one person died
so the wolf moleski family sued jenner
over the crash and their court papers
listed extensive injuries
their two sons one was only a month old
and wolf melissa's mother elga maurer
so uh they had cervical spine wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
she killed a a one month old no no no no
they're
one month old was injured and also uh
it looks like the mother uh had a
cervical
spine fracture according to the lawsuit
they sound like frauds
um they sound like frauds
i i mean i i gotta be honest uh so who
only one person died it seems that one
person and she agreed to pay out
eight hundred thousand dollars to the
family oh enough
enough she can rear-end me
push me in oncoming traffic it is said
that the one month old was injured is he
fine now
yeah immediately was fine but wasn't
responding to stimuli at the scene of
the crash went to the hospital and was
totally fine
she almost killed a baby whatever
i you know it's it's the it's the cancer
culture i don't like
that's that's my biggest problem is the
cancer culture
i don't like to cancel culture
and to cancel her because she almost
killed a baby to me is is unconscious
and
killed a widow just one widow who's what
69 how much more do you got
how many gold medals did that widow win
i don't understand you people not
getting what i'm saying here
we need this woman and we need her now
it is sad i'm happy the baby's okay
had the baby died it only would have
proven my point more
do you think that would have sidelined
her campaign if she killed a one month
old
i don't think so that's what i like
about caitlyn
i think if caitlyn had killed a one
month old baby she still wouldn't really
she might think about it occasionally
but caitlyn knows she knows
can we play her clip yeah i got it right
on the homeless yeah
because this is this is our next
governor
uh in california and i don't live here
don't [ __ ] with me irs i do not live
here
this is a clip of
our next governor or the next governor
of california
speaking about the homeless california
my friends are leaving california i
actually wrote my hair the guy across
front of referee he was packing up his
hangers where are you going
and he says i'm moving to sedona arizona
i can't take it
anymore i can't walk down the streets
and see the homeless
i don't want to leave okay either i
stay and fight or i get out of here
she's going to fight the homeless
this is such an important point of her
campaign
listen to the wording her friend from
across the street
probably a guidance counselor or
something public school teacher i
imagined
bus driver
caitlyn is speaking to her friend and
he's saying i can't do it anymore
i can't look at the homeless
kaitlyn's response is then i don't want
to leave
i want to fight she's going to fight the
homeless
she might go start going on midnight
raids in that escalade
what if caitlyn jenner in her escalade
was just mowing over tent cities
for the betterment of california do you
understand that
driving at an unsafe speed with reckless
abandon
mowing over tent cities mowing over the
homeless
for you the citizen do you get it
don't you get it this woman is trying to
save you
she's just said she will stay in the
state and
fight the homeless for you
presumably you don't want to do it but
she will
can you play the clip i don't know if
you have it queued up i
i know that you're concerned mainly
about the pga golf
championship that's what you spent most
of your time on
and showing everyone your new shirt that
your wife boy what does your wife do
the week of your the month of your
birthday she gets me a present every
week leading up to my birthday
is one of those presents anal
what what now why does she do this she
treats it like hanukkah
is that hanukkah they get a present
every day for eight days
oh yeah yeah so i guess she does like a
a different version of that yeah
now does she get you a big present at
the end or do you just get a present
every week no it's just kind of the same
big present every week what have you
gotten now your birthday is when
june 25th are we even in the month of
june
no she started early because she didn't
want to wait
she gets too excited now
is this the first gift you've gotten uh
i've got two gifts this and then my new
travel bag i have with my initials on it
wow and then the gifts will continue
uh until june 25th when it's your
birthday
your gift for me is your continued
employment
which is subject to constant review
constant review because
quite frankly i don't know
can you play the clip of the jenner
interview
where she speaks about the police yeah
let me find that
because this is the only time in the
interview where caitlyn lied and i have
to call her out
because i respect her she lied
she said every time she sees the cops
she pulls
next to them and says thank you for your
service
can you imagine how startled you would
be as a police officer
if caitlyn jenner just pulled up and was
like thank you for your service bars
and then kept going which she does not
do
uh you can tell she's lying here you can
tell she's being honest when she says my
friends hate looking at the homeless
that's true
but when she says um
when she says something like hey
hey man i just pull over every time i
see a cop
and i say thank you we know that's not
the case
she says thank you to maybe the security
guard uh
at her inner gated community but guess
what even
even no even that no
caitlyn speaks to very few people it's
what i like about caitlyn she has a few
friends
she speaks to and she has a lot of
employees that she barks at
but she does it like you probably say
that you know everyone on the instagram
is like treat ben better i mean
what do you have this up with caitlyn
okay fox news says caitlyn jenner i'm
100 behind our police force and they
have a clip here yes
let's see if this is it i don't know if
it is but
we're here tonight in southern
california for our exclusive interview
with caitlyn jenner running
uh to be the next governor of the great
state of california to replace
gavin newsom let me just ask you about
law and order that we have
you watch the riots this this summer
some democrats
media people wouldn't acknowledge their
riots i have statistics
in la 465 shootings since january
1st up 67 from last year
homicides up 26 when you look at l.a
county
and how many decisions los angeles well
does he do any of that 13
and gavin newsom is going to release 76
000 how many hit and runs
additional inmates for good behavior 63
000 of them committed violent crimes
would you do that not
at all i think on the
releasing of the prisoners um
criminal justice reform is very
important um
and we need to do that okay we need to
rehabilitate people
in prison and bring them back into the
community safely
wow caitlin in his case i don't know how
many of these people have actually been
rehabilitated
to go back into society um
and so i am 100
behind our police force every place i go
um if i see a cop here's a lie if i'm
driving and i see a cop i'll put my hand
out the window and give him a thumbs up
um if they're sitting there i'll pull up
and say hey thank you for your service
you know this citizen appreciates what
you do um i
100 support our police forces she's
lying
um uh as far as
i would be
as many forces as i could possibly use
to stop the writing protect the citizens
and the businesses of this community
um i think that's extremely important
the national guard
whatever we need to keep peace what is
the police
the national guard the marines the green
berets navy seals
delta force direct energy weapons how
great if she just kept going
i would use direct energy weapons sean
you know electronic pulses things like
that
you know any type of thing that we had
radiation
tear gas you know
cluster bombs anything sean
anything to stop the riots any forces
that i could
get my hands on anything
we'll do anything sean we'll never stop
throw a brick to the window of
balenciaga we'll use a direct energy
weapon
i'll i'll i'll tell you right now any
force of sean
at my disposal and i mean anything
i mean i've got friends when we go to
dinner sean they've got weapons you've
never heard of
me and you've never heard of them but
i'm talking about
some real interesting stuff you know
there's things you can do to people with
magnets you you wouldn't
you wouldn't imagine sean
i mean the things you can do to people
with sound do you know this now sean
sound you can pulsate energy waves
through the air
that just knock people down they knock
people right on their ass
any and all weapons at my disposal
i'm talking right now with lori
lightfoot
and we're talking about
well i'm just saying we're supporting
caitlyn that's all
that's what i'm saying we're moving on
from that now but i'm saying we're
supporting caitlyn jenner
because as the the logo of bravo says
watch what happens
you know and i know jimmy kimmel should
honor jimmy kimmel's like is it
transphobic to chlorine a-hole she's
disconnect it's like hey jimmy jimmy
jimmy the joke bombed it's horrible
stop she's funnier than you it's
horrible stop crying on tv
stop pretending like you have any
[ __ ] clue about how to fix the state
or that you give a [ __ ] about the
homeless you make like 25 million
dollars a year
can you stop please this is embarrassing
now you're in bed you did a show called
the man show
you talked about beer and tits you know
this is embarrassing
you're somehow a statesman now well you
and chelsea handler going to go on a
tour and
you know this is embarrassing chelsea
handler by the way hopefully she's
better
she got the modernist shot and i went
deaf in one ear we uh we're sorry to
hear that
we hope uh chelsea gets better we want
her hearing
out of both ears so i can tell her that
she's a [ __ ]
um but uh jimmy kimmel going after
uh our next governor not r i don't live
here
there in the royal sense
we live in texas i can prove it i don't
have to like austin to enjoy where i
live in texas which is a very pretty
area it's very quiet
people have the guts to say things over
coffee like trump was too liberal
uh but i mean we're getting a little
sick of this act which jimmy kimmel can
you please jimmy kimmel joke please
it just bombs horribly is it uh
transphobic to call someone a
a-hole or is it is it not
transphobic because we're not
discriminating against a-holes
god christ almighty is it bad
i want to go swimming later i want to
inflict my body on other people
it's nice to stay at a nice hotel and
inflict yourself on others
it makes them understand that no matter
how much money they spend they can't
really get away from the problems go on
i got it right here yeah please listen
to this uh
tidbit of comedy this is how well
caitlyn jenner understands
the plight of everyday californians here
in l.a
kimmel then showed a clip from her fox
news interview where jenner opened up
about how her friends are quote
leaving california i actually hurt my
hair the guy across front of roof and he
was packing up his hangers where are you
going
and he says i'm moving to uh sedona
arizona i don't take it anywhere
i can't walk down the streets and see
the homeless here was kimmel's response
ah homeless people can't walk around
them can't fly over them you know
the late-night host went on to say this
is it transphobic to call
a trans person an ignorant a-hole i mean
or does calling that trans person an
ignorant a-hole even though she happens
to be a trans person show that we don't
discriminate against ignorant a-holes
for the full late night segment that's
great by the way i love how they get out
of there before the audience doesn't
laugh
uh what a horrible joke just it's wordy
and
bad i mean it's bad huh no no
and the other thing is like i don't know
where does jimmy kimmel live with just
general area uh
like mulholland drive like hollywood
hill do you know
yeah yeah how do you know uh whitney
told us where he lives
right yeah and there's a lot of homeless
people up there right with him
uh matt damon's up there yeah that's my
understanding right
is she's jimmy in the homeless singing
kumbaya
because caitlyn doesn't understand the
needs of everyday californians
but jimmy kimmel does he understands the
needs
of everyday californians okay
whatever better help that's atlp
a lot of people have problems out there
especially getting out of quarantine
there's all these new
anxieties that people are having and you
need to do it you need to go and better
your mental health how do you do it well
you can start communicating in under 48
hours with a professional
counselor online securely there's a
broad range of expertise available which
may not be locally available in many
areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log in your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule a weekly
video
or phone session so you won't ever have
to sit in an uncomfortable waiting room
as with traditional therapy
better help hlp is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today visit their website
and read their testimonials that are
posted daily
visit betterhelp.com tim d that's
betterhelp
and join the over one million people
who've taken charge of their mental
health with the help
of an experienced professional in fact
so many people have been using better
help they're recruiting additional
counselors in all
50 states this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and the tim dillon show
listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.comd
that's 10 off their first month with
betterhelp.com
tim d nobody wants to lose their hair
and one of my good friends
started using keeps keeps helps you keep
the hair that you have
it offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home
low-cost treatment starts at ten dollars
per month and keeps offers generic
versions
of a lot of the more popular hair loss
medications on the market today
discrete packaging and proven results
keeps us more five-star reviews than any
of its competitors
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast i'm telling you two out of three
men will experience some form of hair
loss
by the time they are 35 more than 50
million men in the us suffer from male
pattern baldness
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both
i'm telling you this is the way to do it
if you're ready to take action are you
ready to prevent your hair loss you have
to look at yourself in the mirror and go
i see something happening and i don't
like it but
you can stop it stop it dead in its
tracks go to keeps.com
tim dillon that's keps.com tim dillon to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
tim dillon to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dillon there are
hundreds of companies out there claiming
to compare auto and home insurance rates
but there's only one that actually does
it get better insurance with gabby and i
know it because i've done it
gabby is a one true comparison platform
with fast verifiable quotes not ballpark
guesses
use your current policy to find a better
policy comparing your current coverage
with like 40 of the top insurance
providers like progressive nationwide
and travelers all in one place
it's really easy to do i'm telling you
gabby helped me find the right policy it
was very easy i wanted to make sure that
i was getting the same coverage i wanted
to know if i could save money and gabby
did it easily gabby custer received 961
dollars per year on average
and they'll never sell your info so no
annoying spam or robo calls
put your policy to the test like i did
get better car insurance with gabby
okay it's totally free to check and
there's no obligation
gabby.com tim dillon that's g-a-b-i
dot-com tim dillon it's a great way to
support our show and it's a great way to
save
money on your insurance i use gabby and
i love it for auto and home insurance
rates the best comparisons in real time
to enable you to make the best decisions
gabby.com
bitcoin took a little uh
took a little nosedive uh ben
has been his famously paid in crypto the
whole crypto market
uh [ __ ] the bad ben now owes me money
for being employed on this show bitcoin
lost what let's rattle off some
statistics
uh it's down about 30 it was 44
000 like five days ago and it felt all
the way to 32 and it's back up to like
37 right now as of
yeah but i mean the high was what it was
about almost 60 oh yeah
close to 60 yeah wiped a trillion
dollars off the crypto market now here's
here's my concern we are going to do
a convention in miami in early june
from june 3rd through the 6th it was
going to be the biggest party
of our lives it was going to be a
celebration of cryptocurrency
a celebration of bitcoin a celebration
of narcissism
a celebration of ourselves it was going
to be a gathering of kooks and
criminals and fun people financial
libertarians
people that believed in changing the
world and some of them brilliant some of
them not so much
some people just wanting to you know
talk take some adderall and chat
quarantine had been lifted it was going
to be fun
now i'm wondering how fun is this going
to be
is it going to be dark and gloomy and
sad
i had dinner with the winklevoss twins
the other night they were fans and
wanted to have dinner and we had a nice
dinner in
los angeles and uh they were
smart guys for sure you know i didn't
ask him too much about facebook
i asked him a little but not a lot
they truly true believers crypto
replaces gold it's a reserve currency
they made a lot of great
points i'm with them hey of course i
could see the problem government's
having here
with it the fed's cracking down the irs
you know i tweeted something today
people are mad at me i'm like
you know governments aren't using
bitcoin to finance wars and bailout
people who lost yachts during the
recession
and people like what's preventing them
from doing that i'm like well i'm sure
they could
at one point but you know like all
there's a finite amount of it they just
can't keep
printing it you know every time you know
benjamin netanyahu needs a suitcase nuke
so that was the point of the tweet so i
do understand that you know kind of
revolutionary possibilities of it and
i've talked to some very smart people in
that world i am not
that intelligent i i you know i
understand the rudimentary understanding
of blockchain and
and things like that but there's people
much smarter than me uh
and um you know my lack of autism is a
real problem
i think to be honest and i think
autistic people
are privileged in a weird way because
they have such a laser finite focus
like they really just key in on
something now the smart ones key in on
like blockchain
you know and the other ones key in on
like i don't know something that's not
as
you know like anime something that's not
as profitable
but my lack of autism i'm like not
on the spectrum that i think is a an
issue
do i have asperger can you check read
what asperger maybe i have asperger's
somebody said to me once i think you
have asperger's i'm like i don't think i
do
but i don't know i think it's like a
lack of awareness
in social situations i have a ton of
awareness in social situations i often
just don't care
okay so uh characteristics of a person
with asperger's
intellectual or artistic interest okay
already yes speech differences
i don't know delayed motor development
what does that mean
uh did it take you a while to learn how
to like walk or like use a pencil
no okay poor social skills it took me a
while to sodomize myself
like i didn't try that with my finger
until i was
like older but not that old like teens
uh poor i have great social skills i
just hate everyone
the development of harmful psychological
problems
well yeah that i have
uh detail-oriented no
i would say with architecture and stuff
like that like you notice certain things
yeah but none of it matters right i mean
the details of my own life i lost my
hotel key three times
i lose my wallet i lose everything
uh persistence yes and not socially
driven
uh i don't know what that means i was
socially driven in high school but
people that are socially driven when
they're older
are that's isn't that another problem
yeah
oh and then last two high integrity and
masters of routine
i'll let the audience judge about my
integrity i think i have enough
and then and a man a what a master of
the routine
yeah uh uh like you you you're addicted
to routine
yeah that is not the case i don't think
i have asperger's
i think the person who told me that that
was years ago and that the person who
told me that i believe was wrong
well i just wanted to figure that out
but it was a fun dinner and i texted him
i said would you guys come on the
podcast i'd love to have you on the
podcast to talk about you know the
volatile weekday
and they have not gotten back to me but
that's okay i'm they're busy
it's been a rough week maybe they will
come on and also maybe not
that's a lot of these people are like
yeah we love the thing
but we do not want to be sitting next to
you and that's
fair we are
still trying to get somebody uh to
interview for the bitcoin conference in
miami
it's definitely gonna happen some people
are saying about bitcoin that they have
that the bottom has been reached they
think
and then it's going to climb back up you
know kathy wood you know kathy wood
of course you know kathy wood of course
do you know kathy wood
of arkansas cass do you call her cath
like i do
where does she work arc is her
and she sets price targets doesn't she
yeah she does and
a lot of them are when she sets them
kind of crazy people go we don't think
so
but then she's turned out right like
about tesla correct
interesting you you've been on the cath
wood train
uh i call her cath because i know her
for years
um you've been on the cathy wood train
for a long time
i was in arkg and arkk there for a while
yeah
yeah what do you like about kathy wood
you want to [ __ ] kathy wood
is that what you want to do is that what
you're trying to do
take your big old texas dick and smack
cathy wood in the face with it how dare
you
how dare you she's a ceo she's a ceo
i suppose yeah it's an etf right so
she's like the leader of the etf
she's the leader yeah
but there's a man there right as well
doing all the decisions
uh no i think it's just kathy is kind of
calling all the shots but she has a team
of like
people men yes okay
i'm getting nervous a little nervous
there you know
[Music]
it's not a flower shop this is big
business
the fake business hoodies are out we
were going to wear them on the show of
course they didn't send me my correct
size why why
here's the thing i'll say the quality of
these hoodies is truly amazing
they're soft that the big business
jacket's amazing
it's like [ __ ] you buy in stores it's
really great it's a big step up
i think from the merch we were doing
before which was still good but it's not
nearly as good as this
the people that are involved in merch
are a little brain dead some of these
merch people
you know i mean they're not bad people
but
i mean i mean christ you know
i mean you're not really dealing with i
mean you know this isn't exactly
you know the best and brightest uh out
there in the merch space
let's just be let's just be honest about
it i mean they're they're
lovely people you know that's something
caitlyn jenner would say at the country
club should go there love they're lovely
people but god
not that bright um
but ben did a lot of work on the merge i
uh
i did some i did a lot too the fake
business
stuff is really cool it's really cool
that people
uh dig that bit that we did and it's
very funny and it's a cool
the logo is [ __ ] amazing and
the quality of the [ __ ] is really good
it's soft
what is it what uh is it cotton what is
it polyester
let me take this off what is it i don't
know what it is
but whatever it is it's soft and i have
very sensitive skin and
it hasn't given me a rash the this vest
is 100 polyester
well that's not not good is it
but it is good is it soft for this vest
yeah it's
very soft sometimes you have to use
polyester
get the hoodie see if it's caught let me
see i don't have any problems with
polyester
some people don't like it but they're
stupid
what did kathy woods say about polyester
did she say anything about it has elon
musk tweeted about it
what is the hoodie
it's um let's see here
it's uh 80 cotton 20 polyester
hey 80 20 nothing wrong with that you
need a little polyester
my mother didn't want me to wear
polyester as a child but i was a gay
cocaine addict
so they were worried about all the wrong
things they were worried about polyester
and not
cocaine and the fact that i couldn't get
enough penises
as parents he should have been concerned
about that we are working on
a book called the boomer guide to
parenting which is about the great
parenting strategies that my parents
employed with me
um and there's rules about uh
boomer parenting and we're very excited
about it and it should hopefully you
know
it's a few months away from being ready
but
it's uh really great we look back at the
childhood that a lot of people in my
generation had that are in their you
know mid-30s
and we look back at a lot of the uh
tactics and strategies
uh and lack thereof that our parents
used
when raising us you know they certainly
were not helicopter parents
they were helicopter parents as they
followed the kids around all the time
and they're
right uh the boomers were slightly uh
less involved they were involved in
different ways they used to drop us off
a lot of places
but a deeply selfish generation and uh
we expose them in the book but it's
funny
it's funny all the recollections of
things like when my father told me son
never overestimate your value he was
right about that
he was right he was he was saying just
listen
don't overestimate your value if you
will do it you couldn't say that to a
kid now
they think it's abuse
they were less right about other things
of course and that's the the majority of
the books is the things they weren't
writing about but at the end there's a
chapter where it's like
things boomers got right when raising
their kids the key shouldn't
be a helicopter pattern of course you
don't have to go to the extreme that
they did as well
um you know where like somebody's like
my teacher's molesting me and they're
like will you shut up
but there are there are certain benefits
to the way the boomers parented
and we will get into that are you afraid
uh for the
bitcoin are you uh do you think uh i
just we just have to have it
let's start to build because we have
this convention and i don't really want
it would be funny if these people were
just throwing themselves off balconies
in miami
well i'm seeing some of these [ __ ] coins
like defi 100 are doing exit scams
you seen this yeah well what did that
what did it what did that what
the website said we scammed you and you
can't do anything about it yeah we
scammed you guys and you can't do [ __ ]
about it haha all you moon boys have
been scammed and you can't do [ __ ] about
it
devson [ __ ] you moon boys and they uh
walked away with 32 million in invest
investor funds
well there you go
that's what happens crypto's getting
raked over the coals i think i think the
bubble
uh which it clearly is an asset bubble
but i think people are starting to
realize that
you have one bitcoin and all these other
coins they got people
into crypto which is what i think people
liked about it like the winklevosses
were like well these other coins you
know hey
are they a waste of time we don't know
but they're getting people interested
in the crypto space and they think
long term that's really good so they
tolerate the kind of clownish
element to a lot of the other coins uh
then there are people that are saying
that they think ethereum could overtake
bitcoin i read that
zero hedge dropped that article somebody
was saying that i don't know if it was
an analyst
at goldman or somebody i have three
ethereum for my nft
yeah yeah you do i don't know why my nft
did not sell for more i thought it was
gonna sell for 80 million dollars
or i dressed up like megan mccain
i mean i don't understand what is my
three ethereum worth right now well i
think you wasn't it five ethereum
it was five ethereum that's correct what
is it worth right now let me see the
price of ethereum right now
should i just give that to you and then
have you work for the rest of the year
for free
i mean how much money does he deserve
him and his wife are constantly trying
to get
more out of me the other day he had
something where he said his eyes were
degenerating
so i think she was she probably told him
when they were eating oysters
in some parking lot in texas she
probably goes you're going to pretend to
be blind and this is how we're going to
suck the rest of the money out of him
and i'm just going to i'm going to lead
you around and it'll make him feel bad
we'll like tug on his heartstrings you
know you're his only friend and
everything and
he goes yeah yeah i feel a little bad
about that she goes no no no don't worry
about it
he knows you have glasses anyway you
take them off you're kind of blind as a
bat
pretend to be blind i'll walk you in to
do the show
just just keep looking around the room
we'll give you these big thick black
glasses he won't know the difference and
then we'll tell him your eye operation
costs an insane amount of money
we'll get it from him and then you can
you will we'll rent a
we'll do a whole thing we'll say you're
recovering at home
you know and then we'll just get the
money from them and then you can just
kind of you know go back to the show
and i i think that scam was in place
but i called it out as soon as he
went to the eye doctor i said if you and
your wife are thinking that this is
gonna work or will you pretend
to go blind and that i have to pay for
some crazy
[ __ ] experimental surgery to save you
it'll never happen
i'm not that stupid did you find the
thing i'm talking about
i know oh ethereum yeah yeah yeah so you
you have
11 845 dollars worth of ethereum now
that's yours thank you that's yours
that's yours that's for the that's for
2022.
that's for your work i don't know why
you keep laughing
all he does all him and his wife do is
they're they're just trying to
but i'm very much like caitlyn jenner
like i understand
that the parasites come i understand
what a scavenger is i understand what it
is when somebody
uh you know sees you on the side of the
road
and your carry-on you're a carcass and
that's what him and his wife look at me
as
and they like vultures landing on a
longhorn
how about that texas they just want to
rip my decaying flesh off my body
and i won't let it happen that's why i
support people like caitlyn jenner
people who know who they are
there are some real listen you cannot
buy friends in the world
i've tried it fails i'm telling you
you cannot buy friendship it's really
crazy you think that you could
you should be able to in theory but you
can't
it actually doesn't work but what you
can
buy is the governorship of california
you can do that i mean that's been
proven
so let's do it again is my point
you know it's interesting you can't buy
friends
it's interesting it's it's something
that
you would think you should be able to do
but you can't but money works really
well
why do you think that is you can't buy a
friends
um i guess because then the love is
unconditional right
what like uh you mean the love is
conditional
well yeah then the love isn't
unconditional so the love it would be
conditional
would be the correct way to say that
please pipe down
he ruins everything i try to do
i'm staring at half a bottle of beef
eater gin that i didn't drink my friends
came over
it's their anniversary so i had them
come out here and i made the martinis
because i make martinis very well
in and out we didn't even do vermouth
last night we did the dry so you could
do just gin stir it you don't want to
bruise the gin
you don't want to shake a martini until
it has all those little ice uh you know
that's not what you do
uh chin shouldn't be that cold it should
be chilled
i know a lot about gin but i'm staring
at it you know it's so funny i'm at the
point in my recovery now as an alcoholic
where i don't even want to drink
it i don't even i look at it and i don't
see that it's the solution to any of my
problems
you know i look at it and i go oh that's
funny so that's crazy 10 or 11 years in
11 years into not drinking and doing
drugs
you can stay overnight in a hotel room
with a half bottle of gin and there was
not one
part of me that thought of drinking it
like there was not one part of me there
was not
one uh ember of my being
a fiber of my being whatever that
expression is that i thought you know
maybe i should just sneak a shot
what would a shot feel like you know
would it make the cigarette better
if i just did a little shot just to warm
me up before i go outside
it was not one part of me so i'm i'm
very i'm i'm
proud of that i'm proud of that you can
do a lot sober
that's the thing you have to realize if
you're out there you're struggling
uh with drugs or with uh with quitting
drinking you have to realize
how much you can do sober and then how
this huge part of your life will
eventually not become a part of your
life at all
that's really amazing like this isn't
even a part of my life it's literally
just sitting on a counter
i have no
business with it i have no business with
it
you know what i mean and just to prove
that i drank the whole bottle i said
i am so past this no i'm kidding
ben was funny ben goes it's just i'm
saying all this in the bottle's water
like i just filled it up with water
that's what we used to do to my
grandmother steal her booze and then put
water in and
god love her we miss her um but you
could you could do a lot sober
this thing that's this huge part of your
life and i know a lot of people listen
to the show probably with problems
this huge part of your life actually
becomes not a part of your life
it's amazing it's truly amazing but you
gotta fight
just like caitlyn jenner said you gotta
fight you gotta fight the homeless
you gotta fight them you gotta use every
weapon
at your disposal in the same way that
caitlyn jenner will use a direct energy
weapon
on homeless people you have to use
every ember of your being
to fight the need to pour yourself a
drink because it doesn't
it doesn't fix your problems and it
never will it'll just it'll just
fix them for a short period of time for
a short period of time but it will not
it will not turn things around to turn
things around you got to know who you
are you have to know who you are that
the happiest people in the world aren't
actually that happy
happy people that are overtly happy are
actually
um you know i mean the annoying kind of
happy they're they're
actually not that happy uh they're uh
they're on a drug and the drug is
themselves and it's quite annoying and
it's
troubling if you're in their presence oh
my god
it's like whoa the happiest people in
the world
are caitlyn jenner caitlyn knows exactly
who she is and she always has
it transcends gender it transcends
class she's just caitlyn
that's who she is that's who she'll
always be most at home
eating mexican food served by white
people
at a country club most at home
sitting in the backyard of a mansion
occasionally thinking about the great
things she's done
that's where she is that's why she's the
perfect person to lead the state of
california
because she knows who she is she doesn't
lose sleep she doesn't go what if the
baby died
she doesn't lose sleep over it she goes
i will use any force at my disposal any
force
any force at my disposal doesn't matter
what it is
it doesn't matter what i've got friends
of raytheon the things they can do
sean shawn the things they can do
are are amazing it's it's so funny to me
because shawn like you you
you come from a generation like me where
you had to get out there and shoot
people with guns remember vietnam
you'd have to shoot them with guns in
their face now sean
what you can do with with energy
with vibrations you can do things with
vibrations
that knock people down and you don't
kill them
you don't kill these people you terrify
them you scare them
and they fall down and some of them
might have seizures sure
but what you what you do is you you keep
law and order sean
and i'm very excited uh to really start
using more of those methods and i think
every time i see a police officer every
time i see it i don't care who it is
i don't care if it's derek shelvin i
don't care who it is
i i just pull over my car i just give
him the thumbs up
i give him the thumbs up and
occasionally i yell out the window
who are you killing today boys who are
you shooting today boys
because i'm behind our cops 100 that's
a happy person she doesn't
feel the need to lie to you
or conform to what your idea
of what she should be is she is quite
happily an olympian a father
a mother a murderer and she will
be the next governor of the state of
california
and she will be the next president
of the united states and there will
be hell to pay